so i'm sitting here in my lair in
florida and i'm thinking myself it seems
like all the cool people are moving here
to the free state and then i learned
that dave rubin after many years is
leaving sherman oaks california in his
perfect little world studio in the house
chicken's out back he's abandoning it
all for a new life in the new california
the state of florida and i couldn't be
more thrilled you will improve this
state welcome dave i'm psyched for
dinner when you get here
dave congratulations on the move to
florida i'm so glad you're leaving the
people's republic of california you're
gonna love it you can think for yourself
you can speak for yourself you can
actually be free i know that's hard to
believe
in the united states of america if
you're from california but it's real and
it can happen and you too will
experience it look forward to hanging
out buddy we'll see you soon
already a year ago
i moved to florida i took my entire
company we moved it to nashville and
dave bought a house in california i said
dave that's a real dumb idea what are
you doing well
dave
finally he figured it out now he's
moving to miami so welcome to miami i
hope that you enjoy the cafecito what's
up dave it's your man jonathan isaac i
want to welcome you to the sunshine
state
get here get settled let all the freedom
and the sun hit your pores and let me
know when you're ready to come out to a
game
hey dave welcome to miami or if you like
to call it the 305 i'm not sure what
took you so long but we're glad to have
you here you're going to have a great
time and do great things from florida
dave every time we had a phone call i
was bugging you so when you leave in
california when you leave into
california when you live in california i
should say i'm so glad you're leaving
california welcome to florida it's a
beautiful place can't wait to hang out
with you there you're a great friend you
do terrific work you've always been
there for me and florida's a great place
and hey i got a gift for you
zero
zero percent income tax
have a great christmas dave miss cnu and
welcome to florida god bless
big dave welcome to florida we love
florida it's the only place you can go
out and smoke a cigar or dive into your
pool in january 15th take a couple laps
on christmas we'd love to have you down
here meet you down at the beach house
sometime we can hang out have some
drinks on the beach have a good time
welcome to florida man
freedom's addition to the state good
having you buddy
dave we are pumped to have you down here
in florida wow escaping communism we're
so happy that you were able to do it
maybe you'll have to float here on a
raft who knows i hear that no one can
get anything in or out of california
right now but here's the thing it's a
rule
in florida if you do move here you're
going to have to get the don't tread on
me alligator
tattooed on your [ __ ] stamp seems like
everyone wants to move to florida but
dave you've just done it it's a
fantastic place tropical paradise beacon
of freedom you're gonna love it welcome
so it is december which means it's
freezing in some places
it's during covet still so it's
totalitarian in some other places
but here in florida dave it is warm it
is sunny it is beautiful and most
important it is free welcome to freedom
brother it's great to have you here
well well well dave rubin finally
decided to join us here in florida i
look forward to having you here dave
lots of alligator hunting maybe some
wild boar hunting
fishing stuff to do plenty to do here
but just remember you'll always be free
welcome to the great state of florida
dave
dave
what is this you're leaving california
it can't be because of the homelessness
it can't be because of the crime it
can't be because
more people are leaving this state
than any time in this 170 year history
it can't be because of the crappy
quality of our public education
it can be because of the way this man
shut down the state in a more draconian
way than did any of the other 49
governors
it can't be poor fire management
it can't be rolling brownouts it can't
be because the farmers are now lacking
water i know why you're leaving the
state
because this place just ain't big enough
for the two of us
well
we're gonna miss you bro
have fun in florida
ciao
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell